so I've compiled a list of some things
that I think will at least insulate or
protect you to some degree
potential accusation of a metoo coming
at you in your future
the first very obvious one is obviously
don't do it right
don't don't be a degenerate piece of
[__]
the other ones are more
um you know for those that could be
facing it and
um interact I mean look half the
population is women I know that a lot of
people have this potential solution
world just don't deal with women just go
your own way and stay on your side of
the fence and I don't think that's
entirely practical uh giving the
structure of how we operate with men and
women and why we're here and that sort
of stuff so
one of the things that
one of the first things is of course not
getting yourself in a position where you
can be compromised like look man it's
guys like
um Russell Brand even Andrew Tate like
Tate had to go to full damage control
motion because he knows he's been on a
whole bunch of shows and podcasts prior
to when they made the accusation seeing
bombastic and outlandish things because
it works right like it gets eyeballs
it's red meat people will click on you
you it's more shareable oh look what
this guy said and they forward it to
somebody else so that it gets in front
of somebody else so it works from that
perspective and then he had to go and
get all of these gals to
provide uh video statements testimony I
mean there's got to be a whole team you
know running all that stuff it's it's
got to be a lot of work and
you know when you go out there and you
want to confront the Klaus Schwabs of
the world or the matrixes or the pfizers
you know lots of like there's a reason
why I'm not running a show called
Infowars or anything like that like
I have interesting conversations
privately with people that are on my
inner circle that I've drawn a perimeter
around that I'm close with and all of
these regards right you go out and you
and you cast on a regular basis you put
a Target on yourself
so being invisible so the first tip I
have is be more invisible to the damn
Matrix if that's the word that we're
going to use
there's no reason to paint a Target on
your back now if you go and paint a
Target on your back
fine
but be anti-fragile
there's very very few people out there
that can go up against
The Matrix we'll call it and be entirely
anti-fragile
um on the balance of probabilities
especially most of the people that I've
seen so far because of the lifestyles
that they've leaded LED and how they've
made their money and it's like you know
oh they've got so much money and they've
got these cars and the Jets and the
boats and the hyper cars and all sort of
stuff and it's like
yeah all of those things exist but what
but what was the what was the cost
building up to that like what did you do
how did you earn the money was there
anything uh nefarious was there anything
underhanded did it you know to
compromise anybody that hurt anybody
um you know depending on how they're
going to assess the situation they're
always going to take a look at your past
they're always going to take a you know
take a look at how you've earned money
who you've interacted with who you've
hung out with what you've done with your
time how you hold yourself out to the
public what your reputation looks like
you know they're going to look at these
things and be like ah this guy looks
like a good Target we don't like what
he's saying let's
get some uh accusers who by the way
always remain anonymous or want to
protect their identity right you can't
like it's not revealed until the court
documents are actually presented
obviously so
staying under the radar is not a bad
thing let's just say that the next point
I have after that one two three four
five six I got a few more next point I
have after that is being a long-term
relationship they can't accuse you or
it's going to be very very difficult for
them to accuse you
of Nefarious activity if you're with
somebody especially if you're with
somebody that can corroborate a lot of
the stuff right
you live with somebody you're dating
them you're a long-term relationship I
mean I guess maybe there's a slight
advantage to living to some living with
somebody to avoid it me too even though
I'm not a big fan of living with a gal
or getting married obviously I don't
think they're getting married or living
with a girl is an appropriate remedy to
avoiding Amy to but being in an LTR it's
like oh you you know he touched me or
did that it's like well that's
interesting because I'm always with her
or her story can corroborate you know
your activities together sort of thing
but I think the chances of you getting
me to
um in a modern time a lot long is a key
word here right if you're promiscuous
and
you know like racking up notches big
time
the chances of you being accused of this
and it's sticking or being accused of
this and people looking at you going
there's a chance like like you know
Russell Brand there's a chance because
of his promiscuous past that he may have
done something is it likely I don't
think so it's pretty unlikely again it's
like a guy within a Supercar collection
of 50 cars going and stealing a Kia it
just doesn't add up it doesn't make
sense this guy was spoiled for Choice he
had he had women throwing themselves at
him I don't talk about it very often but
because of my private coaching rate when
I'm dealing with people on an ongoing
basis on a long term I've dealt with
athletes I've dealt with some actors
I've dealt with some politicians
the problems that they have in their
lives and dealing with women female
nature and the stuff that pops up is
very very different from uh you know
like the general public right high level
people uh weapons in the world guys that
are putting very significant dents in
the universe
um they have a different set of problems
but anyway I'll keep going
um keeping records you know we're we're
always tempted and I've done this when
I'm dating right we're always tempted
it's like
she says something that annoys you she's
being a brat or she turns flaky or
whatever and you're like [__] this [__]
and you go and delete it all right
you've lost all the text exchange any
photographs and he I had an awesome time
with you last night can't wait to see
you again like all that's gone poof
right or if or if they're crazy in the
head you know like there's clear
evidence in the messaging back and forth
that she's a Nutter and you're just like
believe this [__] or block her or
something like that then all of a sudden
you've lost it all so
I think in this day and age if you're
dating and you're dealing with women and
multiple women obviously it's prudent to
keep records
just saying you know and never throw
them away so back them up keep them
somewhere
um so
if in 20 years time something comes up
as absurd as that sounds it's entirely
possible the way things are going right
now again we're not seeing a limitation
period on this it's believe all women in
any circumstance anytime regardless of
the duration of time that passes it
doesn't matter right so keep so keeping
uh Records is definitely going to be
useful I think messaging and especially
anything where
um
she's uh you know crazy or you know
expressing that she's a bit of a Nutter
or it's again had such a great time
you're such a gentleman thank you for
taking me out I can't wait to see you
again you know stuff like that obviously
um
let me skip over this next one because I
don't think
creeps are particularly relevant uh to
the people that watch my stuff I mean
bottom line don't don't be creepy like
creepy guys will
there's that there's that Meme from like
Barbara and HR there's two photographs
there's like the creepy weird looking
guy and he's like hey Barb you're
looking good today and she's like hello
HR uh you know Bill is bothering me
again and then the next one is like Chad
thundercock the tall strapping dude with
the square jaw you know muscle bound
wide shoulders narrow waist like the
cartoon character of him and she's like
hey Barb looking good she's like gee
thanks right like women
you know when women are attracted to a
guy
strongly attracted to a guy have genuine
burden desires I discussed in chapter
three of my book which again if you
haven't read read
when women have a strong pull to a guy
it's very obvious
and it's a very secure place to be
for being honest if you get creepy on
her if you're chasing her if you're
getting sippy on her this is where
you're going to run into problems but
again I don't think I mean look if you
guys are plugged in and paying attention
to what I'm talking about you're not
creeps so let's just move on from there
I don't need to spend too much time on
it
um here's an interesting one that I made
a note on is
avoiding
doing things alone with women
um I had a buddy of mine that I was in
business Forum with for a while and
because he saw a friend get me too
he made it a policy that if he had to
meet with any females in his line of
work he always had a third party there
whether it was somebody that worked with
him or somebody that worked with them he
never put himself in a position where he
was ever going to be left alone
for any reason whatsoever with another
woman
um
so whether it was a dinner like if there
was a dinner invitation uh he would say
no problem but I have to bring my
assistant to Kate you know to take notes
um or if there was uh you know like a
private event there was always going to
be other people there if there wasn't
there then he would have to reschedule
and I think
I mean
it's difficult man because it's like
you'd like to kind of go through life
thinking that you can just do it and not
have to worry about some psychopath
trying to ruin you like 10 years later
and you got to keep [__] notes and
not delete stuff and have a third party
there but it makes sense
right like it makes sense especially if
you're a guy that's like married or
you're in a like monogamous type of a
relationship if you're ever going to get
accused of cheating or some [__] like
that you've got a third party it's like
yeah what are you talking about right so
not putting yourself in an environment
where you can be accused of it is
probably a smart thing to do as well
take it for what you want
um ties in with space and distance and I
think the last note before we start
taking some of these call-ins here
and I will get to the call and we'll get
we'll get lots of time for these tonight
is managing your reputation right
um
you ask anybody that's known me for a
long time you'll get a very accurate
description of who I am the kind of man
that I am how I lead my life how I treat
people
um all that stuff you'll get a very
clear concise and consistent man you
know uh message on my reputation what
your reputation is outside of that like
there's some weirdos out on the internet
just being honest with you like people
are all like well Rich why don't you uh
you know ask me a question on a podcast
about like what's your age or something
like that I'll just be like my answer to
that is I'm a kid of the I'm a product
of the 70s you know I'm a kid of the 70s
sort of thing why do you want to tell us
your age well I worked in credit
facilities and credit card collections
and stuff like that and I understand
very well how data is collected how they
collect data how you can reverse data do
reverse lookups and things like that so
I think it's prudent to not give out
information that doesn't that isn't
relevant to you know discussion saying
that I'm a a pro to the 70s is more than
sufficient in my opinion but beyond the
opinions of that people are going to
make up [__] oh he's not going to tell
you because he's older than he says he
is he's younger he's on this [__]
hormone or like
they've got more stories of Walt Disney
it's funny because I stopped reading the
comments a long time ago
but
you know I was looking at them like
you'd read some just weird [__] like you
think you know me bro or some woman
would say something's like yeah okay
this guy's an end South yeah okay
so managing your reputation within the
people that you're in contact with and
you know with your circle really really
matters be polite be a gentleman
um be a man of your world word be
impeccable you know with your word when
you're talking business when you're
talking anything you know related to
your reputation
do what you say you're gonna do
it's simple do what you say you're going
to do right like be a man you're like it
seems so easy and simple to say but
there's a lot of real pieces of [__] out
there these days that will do anything
them to to take money from you right or
to take away from your reputation or or
anything that you've built for yourself
a lot of the times it's you know because
of envy and jealousy and they just do
these things because it's like it's
easier and more fun for them than doing
the work right so managing your
reputation as far as you can control it
is is a wonderful approach to life in
general I think I don't think that you
should do this just to avoid being me
too but I think that managing your
reputations incredibly important as far
as a life hack you know as a guy let
people on the outside say whatever they
want about you I you know like these dip
shits will go and make up all kinds of
stories about me and they'll make videos
and they'll say stuff and every time I
ever looked at one in the past it's all
[__] made up [__] like 99 of it is
just [__] and the one percent that's
not it's exaggerated truth manage your
reputation that you can control that's
the important aspect of this very
important to do that I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out